In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinaxadion, for June 20th, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Calistos I, patriarch of Constantinople.
Our Holy Father Calistos was first among in the great Lavra, and then became a disciple
of St. Gregory the Sinite, at the Skit of Maghulah.
He lived for long years under the direction of this master of Hezekhazim, whose life he wrote.
Frequently threatened by Turkish pirates, St. Gregory and his disciples, including Calistos,
left Athos in 1326 and wandered from place to place through Thessalonica, Heels, Metilini
and Thrace, before fixing their retreat in the desert of Paroria on the Bulgarian frontier.
Oblied once again to flee from Briggins, they remained in Constantinople, and sometime later
St. Gregory was able to return to Paroria, receiving the protection of John Alexander, Zar of Bulgaria.
Calistos decided to return to Athos in 1331.
He was in the Skit of Maghulah when St. Athanasius, the founder of the Meteora, presented himself
there, and it was Calistos who sent him to the older Gregory at Millea.
Calistos then settled in the monastery of Ividon, of which he may have become abbot, and was
charged with important missions to Constantinople by the authorities of the Holy Mountain.
On the 10th of June 1350, he was elected Ecumenical Patriarch, and the following year presided
at the Synod that confirmed the doctrine of St. Gregory Palamas, on the deification of
human beings by uncreated energies.
Two years later, John Katakusannus wished him to crown his son Matthew as emperor, and
to suppress any mention in the liturgy of John V. Beliologos, the legitimate emperor.
But the Holy Hierarch remained faithful to the principle of dynastic legitimacy and retired
to the monastery of St. Athanasius, and afterwards that of St. Mama's, without, however, consenting
to resign, a position which prevented the coronation of the usurper.
On the 14th of August in 1353, the Holy Synod pronounced his deposition, and replaced him
with the Metropolitan of Heraclia, St. Philotheos, who in February 1354 crowned Matthew, Katakusannus,
as co-emperor.
Calistus then went to Tenedos, where John V. Beliologos, the exiled emperor, was living,
and he continued to act as though still patriarch.
After the return of John Beliologos to Constantinople and the signing of an agreement by the two
rival emperors, which was concluded by the resignation of Katakusannus and his taking
of the monastic habit, St. Calistus was re-established on the patriarchal throne, while St.
Philotheos was cast aside.
During this second term as patriarch, he labored for the defense of the privileges of the ecumenical
patriarch and for the re-establishment of harmony between the Church and civil authorities.
And on a mission to set us to the Serbian Zarista Helena to obtain military aid against
the Turks, the Holy Patriarch visited Athos on route, where he met with St. Maximus,
the Kavso-Calivite, who predicted his approaching death.
And indeed it was in August 1363 during this mission that he died of an epidemic, as did
the majority of the dignitaries of his retinue.
The Holy Synod then re-established Philotheos on the patriarchal throne.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.